Abby Lee Miller the past couple of years
have really been rough for the dance mom
star she was diagnosed with cancer and
before that served time in prison for
tax evasion yes so Abby Lee can really
relate to the Hollywood moms in the
middle of the college admissions scandal
who could be facing the same fate there
are some other celebrities that have
gotten themselves in a bit of trouble
Felicity and Lori Loughlin
any advice to them lots of a nice be
open with people they are celebrities
people know them from TV I think if they
share their their stories and their
tales of woe and all that that they will
be just fine what's the worst thing that
you would prepare them for the guards
more so the female guards than the male
you don't need a lot of credentials to
be a prison guard in a federal prison
and you know you give them a set of keys
and a weapon and they're in power how
did the other women in prison react to
you coming and had they been fans did
they was it weird to be a celebrity it's
just like any other place that I go some
people love me some people hated me you
know one lady took the shoes off of her
feet and gave him to me there isn't a
mother on the cast of Dance Moms that
would have given me the shoes off her
feet
on June 4th all that drama returns when
Dance Moms resurrection premieres on
lifetime Abby has been wheelchair-bound
ever since undergoing chemotherapy to
conquer non-hodgkins lymphoma
hard to be here and you have to be a
fighter tip right now we're kind of at a
plateau I'm walking I can do
step-ball-change with parallel bars or
with a walker but when I try to lock out
my right leg to take us up with my left
I just crumble I'm dependent upon
strangers and the kindness of other
people so I think that that has changed
[Music]